in a world full of shade
we all shine through
are you ready squirrel friends season 13
of mega hit reality competition series
rupaul's drag race will premiere on new
year's day
what a way to kick off 2021 and the
queens that we met today
may just be the fiercest yet
[Music]
see this is going to be such a great
season and a season of firsts for the
very first time we have a trans man
competing on the main stage
it means so much for me to be on the
show right now especially being a trans
guy going in
a feminine perspective of a trans guy
the
trans movement is getting so big so
powerful so strong and as we've come to
expect there are drag family connections
kimura hall is drag's sister to season
12 winner
jada essence hall now unfortunately like
we have seen in previous seasons with
brooklyn heights and jackie cox
there are no canadian queens to root for
but luckily
we have the incredible first season of
canada's drag race to binge
i know i can't wait to start off my 2021
with
a brand new season of drag race thank
you so much
mamaroo this is truly a gift
so do you think we'll see a returning
queen from season 12
on this season of drag race which queens
are really standing out to you so far
they are all so good but from the
initial first meeting of them
i have to say my favorites are joey j
kamora hall candy muse and simone make
sure you let me know your thoughts on
the season 13 queens
in the comments below
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos